翻訳: keitaro hoshino
校正: Hiroko Kawano
皆さんこんにちは
今日 私はですね
「志というものは みつけるものではなくて
皆さんが日々のことを
一生懸命にやることによって
心に作られるものだ」という話を
したいと思っています
そのために 私の実際の 実例 —
私の経験を話すことによって
何か皆さんの参考になると
いうふうに思っています
今日ここには 日本語が全くわからないと
いう人も 何人かいらっしゃるということなので
その後に 最後で英語で少しお話をします
私の話なのですが
今 私は 東北におりまして
妻と一緒に住んでいるのですが
東北のビジネスパーソンたちがですね
本当に自分の能力とか
ビジネススキルとかを高めるために —
そういった 仲間とともに
高める場所を作ろうと思って
思いを持って 志を持って
今 仙台で仕事をしています
そのきっかけは
震災（東日本大震災）があって
最初 ボランティアで
東北に参ったんですけれども
そこで強烈に「自分に何ができるんだろう」
という強い思いを持ちました
その結果 自分のビジネススクールがですね
仙台に学校を作るっていう話があったので
手を挙げて
「私に作らせてください」ということで
立ち上げメンバーとして来ました
今 その志を強く持って
仕事をしているんですけれども
もう５年経ちまして
多くの皆さんが
「どうやってその志って立てたんですか？」
とかですね
あと それとセットでよく「私なかなか
そういう志をみつけられないんです」
みたいな話をよくされます
私は 自分のことを振り返るとですね
その経験というか そのきっかけは
自分の大学時代にあったなと思います
私は 大学時代
本当に苦しい時期がありました
それはですね 本当に
「何をやればいいか分からない」
という時期ですね
体も健康だし 友達も多かったし
草サッカーとか 草野球とかやりながら
あんまりクラスには出なかったんですけど
日々の楽しい生活を営みながら
でも ふと考えると
「何をすればいいんだろう？」って
迷ってしまう と
周りの友達たちはみんな
就職活動を始めていくし
あと社会人たちが言うんですよ
「一生懸命に何か早くみつけろ」
みたいな
「やりたいことをみつけろ
時間がもったいないぞ」って言うんですよね
そんな中でどんどん自分を
追い込んでいって苦しかった
それに加えて私は種子島の出身で
親から仕送りをしてもらっていました
なので 種子島の田舎で
本当に一所懸命に働く親がですね
そういう仕送りをしてまで
私にこうお金をくださるのに
「何かみつけなきゃ」っていう
苦しい気持ちがあった
ある時も 本当に苦しすぎて
もう耐えきれないっていうレベルまで
苦しい気持ちになった時に
もう耐えきれないので
せめて自分が関わっていることとか
自分が興味を持っていることに対して
ちょっと踏み出して
自分の目で見に行こうと思いました
私の種子島の実家というのが
和牛ですね —
黒毛和牛の農家をやっていたので
ひとつ黒毛和牛の農家を自分の足で訪ねて
そこで色々なことを勉強しようと思いました
まずやったことは
日本中の農家に電話しまくってですね —
アポ取ってですね
「会わしてください」って言って
会いに行ったんです
８割くらいは断られるんですけど
２割くらいの方が会ってくれるし
会いに行っても ただ話すだけじゃなくて
一緒にご飯食べたり あと一緒に農業したりとか
時には家に上がり込んで
話をして飲んだりとかですね
そういうことを繰り返していく中で
日本の和牛農家の現状が分かりました
分かったら次は
どうも日本の和牛業界というのは
研究を非常に大事にやっていることが
分かったので
また 研究所に電話をして アポ取って
日本中の研究所を回りました
研究所を回ると 今度は
日本の畜産業界を分かるためには
日本を出て海外から日本を見ないと
分からないことに気づいたので
今度はオーストラリアに電話して
オーストラリアの和牛の —
そういった組織のトップの方に電話して
「すぐ会わせてくれ」って言って
オーストラリアへ会いに行きました
オーストラリアへ行ったら 今度は
オーストラリアに一杯農家が
いることが分かったので
10 [軒の] 農家くらい 全員にアポ取って
ホームステイをして
そこでオーストラリアの農業
というのを勉強しました
畜産ですね
そして オーストラリアで勉強していると
今度は 世界的な肉食の「肉」の —
食肉の選手権があるって分かったんです
なんか格付けをするような
なので それに出るために
日本代表として
出なきゃいけないので
日本に戻って今度は 東京の品川にある
食肉センターのトップにまた連絡をして
「私をトレーニングしてください」
と言ってですね
トレーニングをしてもらって
世界選手権に日本代表として出ました
そこまで行くと分かってきたことが —
どうも 日本とオーストラリアの
農業の 畜産の違いというのは
日本の農家というのは
非常に売上重視 —
「隣の人よりも高い牛を
作ることが大事だ」みたいな —
市場に行って負けたくないんですよ
隣の人に
ところが オーストラリアの農家っていうのは
コストと利益重視 —
だから別にいくらで売れるかではなくて
どれだけ利益出したかにフォーカスをしている
その結果
非常に違いが出ていたのが分かった
そこまで分かった瞬間に
私は やり切った感があったんですよ
「和牛に関しては自分はやり切った」
という強い思いがなんか芽生えてきて
「よし これでもう終わろう」と思いました
で 就活が始まるその時には
自分がその和牛の経験で得た
「財務とか経理が大事だ」
という思いをベースに就活を始めて
日本で当時非常に財務や経理に
力を入れている会社があったんで
そこに就職をして
財務や経理の仕事を始めました
ところがですね
入ってすぐに気づくんですね
「財務経理 あまり好きじゃないな」って
気づくんです
ところがですね 気づいても
やっぱり やり切りたかったんですよね
和牛の時に得た「やり切る感」というのを
ちゃんとやるんだっていうことを
逃げずに がんばりました
やり切ったタイミングで
当時ですね
私が勤めた財務や経理の会社というのは
非常にリーダー育成に
力を入れている会社だったので
リーダー教育に貢献しようと思って
今のビジネススクールに転職をしたのが
[2011年] 3月1日でした
大震災の10日前だったんですね
10日前
その後のストーリーというのは
冒頭申し上げたように
月～金は 東京で仕事をしていたので
土日は 東北に来て
ボランティアをやっていました
それを繰り返していくうちに
仙台校を作るという話ができたので
そこに私がジョインして
立ち上げを行いました
そこで私が気づくのは
志をみつけようとして探していた時は
本当に辛かったんです —
どこにも落ちていないし
「自分をみつけろ」ってみんな言うけど
どこにも落ちていない —
探せない
だけど 自分のやるべきこと —
目の前の仕事とか
目の前の学業でも良いでしょう —
学生の方は 良いと思いますけど
自分が少しでも興味あることとか
関わっていることを全力でやり切ってみる
やり切ることを繰り返していくうちに
自分の中に志というのが出来上がってきました
なので皆さん迷っている方とか
苦しい思いを抱えている方がいらっしゃったら
ぜひ一旦自分の「志をみつける」
ということは忘れて
自分が取り組んでいることとか
もしくは自分が少しでも興味があることに
もうちょっと踏み込んでやり切って欲しい
そういうふうに思っています
どうもありがとうございました
失礼します
（拍手）